Good evening and welcome to Finepoint,
where no narrative is sacred, no media
hoax is safe, and we zero in on the big
picture. I'm your host, Chanel Rion. Can
you feel it in the wind? It's 1775
again.
All this talk about how much money the
cutteries are pedalling to influence
conservatives like Tucker against
Israel, that's just scratching the
surface. The cutteries are the left hand
of China. And Venezuela confirms it.
America is eight weeks into a military
campaign against Venezuela and Colombia.
And as I've said before, this is just a
cover story. Yes, we're taking out narot
terrorists and making socialist
dictators quake, but really this is an
allout war against communist China and
China's grip on the weakest chains in
our hemisphere. China owns Venezuela.
$60 billion in debt with every port
controlled by China. Doesn't take a
genius to figure that out. But a new
angle of the story has just emerged. So
whenever you hear cutter, think China.
In an exclusive report by the Miami
Herald, we learned that earlier this
year, the cutteries were neck deep
trying to mediate a more acceptable
regime change in Venezuela. Team Trump
rejected it. Listen to this. According
to the Herald, the Venezuelan vice
president, Deli Rodriguez, and her
brother Jorge, the president of the
National Assembly, quietly lobbyed
Washington, presenting themselves as the
more acceptable alternative to
Venezuelan dictator Nicholas Maduro.
They funneled these proposals through
the cutteries. The cutteries presented
the US with two formal proposals, one in
April and one in September.
The pitch was this. The Rodriguez
siblings were not associated with narco
terrorists. They could continue a smooth
transition and they'd do this peacefully
all while giving Maduro asylum in Turkey
or Qatar.
Secretary of State Rubio and President
Trump took two glances at this deal and
said absolutely not. This was just
Maduro China light. Trump was not being
fooled. So back up. How are the cut
cutteries involved in Venezuela? Well,
great question. Turns out when Trump was
turning up the heat on Venezuela earlier
this year, the cutteries intensified
their lobbying efforts in the United
States on behalf of Caracus.
You see, US officials have accused Qatar
of providing shelter for Venezuelan
dirty money, especially the dirty money
of the ruling elite. Vice President Deli
Rodriguez maintains, according to the
Herald, a significant relationship with
members of the Qatari for royal family
and it is with them she hides assets.
Why does she hide assets? Well, she's
not as detached from the cartels as the
cutteries have presented her and Trump
knows it. Turns out Deli and her brother
are tied to money laundering and
logistics for a cartel of the Suns. the
cartel state department says is linked
to Maduro. All this was presented first
to US special envoy Rick Grenell who
then relayed all of this back to
Washington while he was rescuing US
citizens jailed in Venezuela. Neither
Grenell nor State Department have
commented on this story. And why would
they? America wouldn't even consider the
plan. But it does give us some very
important context. The hardliners inside
Trump world, the Rubios, who know a lot
about Latin America and how it is a
front for China's US invasion, knew this
was a meaningless offer born of sheer
desperation
and that cutter is a handmaiden for
China and is now their mediator. Cutter
is trying to save China's foothold in
the Western Hemisphere. You don't
negotiate regime change and trade one
narotist puppet for a different set of
naroterrorist puppets and think we'll
just go along with that. We're
not.Qatar, who outspends nearly every
country in the world, lobbying right
here in Washington, is also not some
independent nation either. Qatar is a
China proxy. Qatar and China have a deep
partnership that goes back officially to
1988.
China is Qatar's largest trade partner.
Qatar exports oil and gas, and China
imports goods and services. They're
joined at the hip. But it turns out
there are deeper ties between China
andQatar. It's historical and
geographical as well. They've been
longtime partners since the Silk Road
days, and their relationship has only
blossomed and bloomed intoQatar playing
a key partner to China's belt and road
initiative.
In September, the same month cutter
tried to push this China light solution
in Venezuela. An article in Doha wrote,
quote, "The cutter China relationship is
currently experiencing its highest level
in history, standing as a model of
friendly cooperation and strategic
partnership," said an official. The
cutter China relationship is touted by
both sides as being in a golden age.
Chinese officials in Qatar praised the
friendship between she and the Amir ofQ
ofQ ofQ ofQ ofQ ofQ ofQ ofQ ofQ ofQatar
just this last month and just to
reiterate I've been saying the Beijing
Bannon crowd are one and the same
remember well the Beijing Bannon crowd
is siding with China against Trump on
Iran Gaza and Israel and would it
surprise you that the Beijing Bannon
crowd has been attacking Marco Rubio and
attacking Trump's Venezuela moves too
what a coincidence
Turns out again, this is exactly how
China feels about the situation. And
China is using everything in its toolbox
to try and hold on to Latin America.
From ensuring the Bannon Tucker Candace
crowd mimics China's every talking point
to leveraging China's left-hand men, the
cutteries.
And Trump is buying none of it. Here to
weigh in is the founding director of
Jihad Watch and New York Times
best-selling author, Robert Spencer.
Robert, thank you so much for joining
us. I want your reaction to what I laid
out there and maybe give us some context
about howQatar's relationship with China
is something that we don't really talk
about.
>> Thank you, Chanel. You know, this is
really the highest point of the red
green axis, which is something that we
see playing out all over the world
today. When you see, for example, on
college campuses all these indoctrinated
bots, these young students out there
agitating for Hamas, they have been
indoctrinated by university professors
at universities who that are massively
funded by Qatar. And Qatar and China are
working together to destabilize and
ultimately destroy the West. the idea
the the reason why the left and the
Islamic world and remember Qatar is the
chief sponsor of the Muslim Brotherhood
in the in the whole western world and
particularly in the United States. The
reason why they are so closely aligned
is out of a shared hatred for America, a
shared authoritarianism and a desire to
destroy America because it presents the
chief competition to the
internationalist authoritarian regimes
that they envision. And so I I I really
applaud you for bringing to light all of
this when we have Qatar working with
China with the Belt and Road initiative
not only in Latin America but also all
across Central Asia in Pakistan,
Afghanistan and its envir their
environs. This is something that the
United States ignores at its own peril.
You know, Robert, what's alarming though
is cutter has a lot of money and China
does too. China spends it in ways that
are a little more underhanded. Cutter is
not as afraid to waltz around Washington
DC and court Republicans, court
conservatives. I mean, the cutteries
have made some real inroads with the
right.
>> Oh yeah, absolutely. Well, it cannot be
uh underestimated that Qatar has spent
millions of dollars targeting
particularly Trump supporters. And so I
thought this is great that you're
calling out the Bannon group and Candace
and so on because this is the fruit of
this Qatari influence operation. These
are the things that they have paid for
and they're getting their money's worth
in splitting the right and making
conservatives turn against what has been
the positions that patriots have taken
all these years. And so it's been an
extraordinarily successful effort,
extremely skillfully deployed, but
ultimately it just comes down to the
bottom line. And as you say, Qatar and
China both, they got plenty of money.
Well, it's also shortsighted to just say
it's cutter. I mean, I mean, that's the
broader point, right? The broader point
is this kind of marriage, this union. On
the surface, I think a lot of analysts
miss the point when they say, well, it's
cutter just trying to be uh the new
Switzerland. They're trying to make
friends with everybody. I don't think
that's necessarily the case, especially
when you look at their ideological
history. When you look at their
long-term friendship with China, it's
shortsighted to say this is just Qatar,
it is when you say Qatar, you also have
to mention China.
>> Oh yeah, absolutely. And we have to bear
in mind that this mediating role that
they are assuming both with Hamas and
Israel and now in Venezuela and
everywhere else that they can make it
stick, this mediating role is really
just a way to play both sides against
each other and to try ultimately to gain
an advantage for itself and its allies.
Uh, Robert, before I let you go, uh, you
are actually working on another book,
um, Inifat on the Hudson, the selling of
Zuron Mandani. Uh, what a timely title.
I know we're just, we're not very far
out from this mayoral race. And either
way, I think it's going to be very
important people understand the
background of M Donnie here, his
ideological upbringings. I think you
really dive into that in this new book.
Yeah, it's just out now. It's available
at Amazon. And the uh funny thing is
Mandani kind of personifies
what China and Qatar are doing on a
national and international level because
he is both a Marxist although he denies
it. It's very clear and I have the
receipts in the book. He's not only a
Marxist but a 12 or Shiite Muslim. that
is he's an adherent of the official
religion of the Islamic Republic of Iran
where they chant death to America in the
mosques every week by order of the
government and the supreme leader of
Iran has said this is not just a slogan
this is a policy this is the mission and
goal of our regime so imagine the damage
a man like that could do as mayor of New
York
>> wow Zoran Mandani is the love child
between communist China and the Muslim
Brotherhood there is an image
Robert Spencer, we look forward to
reading the book.
>> Thank you for your time and we always
appreciate it when you drop by.
>> Thanks very much. Always good to talk to
you.
>> Coming up, Curtis Leewa, speaking of New
York, walked off his show after pressure
from his own boss to drop out of the New
York mayoral race. Remember, Siwa is
running for Republican candidate out
there and everyone says he's going to
spoil the race. Former New York City
Congressman George Santos weighs in on
the latest in that race. We'll be
[music] right back.
[music]